traditional Chinese doctors go into
people's houses to diagnose why it is
that someone in that house is suffering
and they walk in and they think there's
too much order here I've been in houses
like that that's a house where all the
furniture is covered with plastic that's
a house where if you put a glass on a
wooden table the mistress of the house
runs over with the coaster slips it
under immediately and gives you a dirty
look that's a place where the children
never play in the living room that's a
place where the lines in the carpet are
vacuumed so precisely that they're
actually parallel that's a place where
there's so much order that no one can
survive because the person who runs the
house is a tyrant and that anyone who's
sick in that house is sick because
they're suffering from an excess of
order and then you can walk into a house
that's completely different and you can
even see this in your own room if you
want everything's in complete disarray
you can't even look at that place you're
sick the moment you cross the threshold
because everywhere you look there's
parts of untransformed chaos yelling to
you do something about this
loser